ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قال وزير الدوله
لشؤون الخارجيه ومبعوث شؤون المناخ في
السعوديه عدل الجبير قال ان موضوع التغير
المناخي ممتلئ بالمشاعر والعواطف بما يصدم
المنطق والعلم وتوجد فيه تناقضات منها على
سبيل المثال فرض الدول الاوروبيه ضرائب
تبلغ 200 بالمئه على البترول وفي الوقت
نفسه يقدمون مساعدات للفحم الاسود تاثيرا
على المناخ من البترول واضاف الوزير في
مقابله خاصه مع قناه العربيه على هامشي
مؤتمر المناخ في شرم الشيخ ان فتره ما قبل
الازمه الاوكرانيه كانت هناك مطالباتهم
بعدم الاعتماد على البترول والفحم وبعد
الازمه ظهرت مطالبه برفع انتاج البترول
والفحم ولذلك فان اساس هذه المواقف
المتناقضه الحوار غير المبني على المنطقه
والعلمه وقال الجبير ان الوقود الاحفوري
سيستمر مع العالم لعقود والتحول قد سيحدث
تدريجيا ولن يحدث بين يوم وليله وفيما
ترتفع الحاجه الى الطاقه في العالم فانه
لا يمكن تربيتها الا بايجاد مصادر طاقه
بديله كالشمس والرياح لان انتاج البترول
له حظ معين لا يمكن زياده عنه
هناك مطالبات بعدم الاعتماد على
البترول والفحم
وبعد ما صارت الازمه في اوكرانيا صار في
مطالبات برفع انتاج الفحم والبترول هذه
المناطق هذه هذه المواقف المتناقضه
اساسها
الحوار الذي ليس مبني على منطق وعلى امور
علميه الدول الاوروبيه تفرز ضرائب 200 في
الميه على البترول واحد الحجاج انه المناخ
في نفس الوقت يقدمون مساعدات للفحم الذي
اسوا للمناخ من البترول المنطقه
داخل من عندنا امكانيه تنفسيه في ان نصدر
طاقه
هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الرياض محمد
العمران رئيس مركز الخليجي للاستشارات
الماليه وبعد قليل سينظمين كذلك من باريس
الدكتور بدوي رهبان خبير وتغير المناخ
والكوارث الطبيعيه اهلا بك استاذ محمد
وتعاطي الدول الاوروبيه والغرب عموما مع
موضوع الطاقه والمناخ يقول البعض بان
الافعال تختلف تماما على الاقوال او عن
الاقوال وزير الدوله لشؤون الخارجيه
ومبعوث وشؤون المناخ في السعوديه عادل
الجوبير تحدث عن تنقضات يعيشها الغرب في
ما يخص هذا الموضوع ما تفسيرك لهذه
التناقضات
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
طبعا يعني كلام مالي الوزير كلام صحيح وهو
لم يذكر كامل تناقضات هو اعطى بعض الامثله
لان هناك تناقضات اخرى كثيره يعني من
ضمنها مثلا عدم تشجيع صناعه او استخراج
الوقود الاحفوري في الولايات المتحده وفي
نفس الوقت يسحبون من المخزون الاستراتيجي
عده مرات ايضا يطالبون المملكه بزياده
الانتاج وزياده الطاقات الانتاجيه في
الوقت اللي شركات الامريكيه نفسها لا
تستثمر اطلاقانا او لا تنفق في راس ماليا
في لتوسيع الطاقات الانتاجيه همم من
الوقود الاحفوري تناقضات كثيره في الحقيقه
لكن طبعا المشكله الاساسيه ان مشكله
التضخم اللي بدات تعاني منها دول الغرب
تحديد الولايات المتحده واوروبا وهي طبعا
ليست بسبب النفط فقط لا لها اسباب اخرى
اكثر تعقيدا يعني وبالتالي هم يحاولون
العرب من المشكله الاساسيه ويضعون اللون
فقط على النفط بالوقت اللي مثل ما ذكر سمو
الامير عبد العزيز في اجتماع احد
الاجتماعات واوضح ان اسعار النفط اصلا لم
تشهد ارتفاعات قويه مثل الارتفاعات القويه
لشهدتها اسعارها الفحم او الغازي الطبيعي
على سبيل المثال اللي ارتفع بمضاعفات يعني
في الوقت اللي اليوم في نوفمبر 2022
بالمقارنه مع نوفمبر من العمل الماضي
تقريبا اسعار النفط عند نقطه الصفر لم
ترتفع الارتفاعات العاليه وبالتالي التضخم
يعتبر هو المشكله الاساسيه والتضخم مثل ما
معروف ارهااصاتها الاولى بدات تظهر في
الولايات المتحده من العام الماضي والبنك
الفيدرالي تجاهل هذا ال- ال- الارتفاع
وبالتالي ضخ امال ضخمه يعني تقريبا احنا
نتكلم عن 25% تقريبا من المعروض النقدي في
الولايات المتحده تم ضخها خلال سنتين
الثلاثه الاخيره وهو رقم كبير جدا يعني
وبالتالي كان من الطبيعي لنشوف الضخم
الاموال هذا من خلال حزم التحفيز المالي
ان بدايه على ارتفاعات قويه في اسعار
الاسهم ثم ايضا باسعار المساكن ثم اسعار
الايجارات وبالتالي ارتفعت تضخم ومع الاسف
يعني يضعون اللوم على جزء بسيط يتعلق
بالنفط وهو بريء تماما في الوقت المشكله
الاساسيه يعني
استاذ محمد هل ترى بان هذه التناقضات
سببها عدم توفر حلول حقيقيه للقاده ااه في
الغرب بمعنى انه مجبر اخاك على بطل
يحاولون ولكن ليست لديهم حلول او انك
بالعكس ترى بانه هذه التناقضات سببها او
شيء منها تلاعب همم
ومحاوله همم الترويج لشيء همم عكس ما هو
موجود حقيقه او عكس ما يرون في الواقع
اتفضلتي يعني لا ننسى انه مشكله الاحتباس
الحراري ومشكله المناخ العالميه يعني
بالدرجه الاولى هي مشكله تحتاج حلول طويله
المدى المشكله ان بعض السياسيين في الدول
الغربيه نظرتهم محدوده قصيره الاجل ومع
الاسف تم تسييس مشكله المناخ لتحقيق مكاسب
سياسيه او اقتصاديه بعيدا عن ايجاد حلول
همم طبعا هم معظم الدول يعني تتكلم وتتحدث
عن ان نقطه الحياد الكربوني عندهم بعد 20
او 30 سنه لكن الى هذه اللحظه لا نشاهد
تنفيذ مبادرات حقيقيه وملموسه لحل هذه
المشكله وبالتالي نجد حلول قصيره المدى
بسبب ان السياسيين اساسا على كراسهم
لفترات سنوات قليله يعني وبالتالي لا
يوجدون حلول جذريه طويله المدى لهذا
المشكله بالتعاون مع بقيه الدول الكبرى لا
ننسى اختي الكريمه ان ااه مشكله الاحتباس
الحرا حسب التقارير توضح ان دول امريكا
الشماليه واوروبا اضافه الى الصين
واليابان وروسيا والهند هم المتسببين بهذه
المشكله بالنسبه لا تقل عن 75% هذا اليوم
يعني في الوقت اللي هذه الدول اللي تسببت
بهذه المشكله يعني يعني بطيئه جدا او لا
تتفاعل مع يعني حل هذه المشكله بايجاد
مبادرات كما قامت فيها المملكه يعني ممثله
بسمو ولي العهد عندما اعلنت عن موبايل
اكثر من 60 مبادره من ضمنها مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر والعديد من الدول الاخرى وهناك
تقرير ايضا من صندوق النقد الدولي يوضح ان
ارتفاع درجه الحراره في الكره الارضيه لن
يكون تاثيراتها متساويه على بقيه الدول
العالم بمعنى ان الدول اللي هتتاثر سلبا
اكثر هي في الحقيقه ليست من ضمن الدول
اللي سببت هذه المشكله وهي في الغالب يعني
دول افريقيا واسيا وامريكا الجنوبيه وطبعا
دول الشرق الاوسط وهذا يوضح ان المتسبب
بعيدا تماما عن الت في الوقت اللي الدول
اللي اكثر تاثيرا هي اللي قاعد تاخذ على
نفسها مبادرات لحل هذه المشكله
السياسيه في الدول الغرب انهم يعني يجيدون
حلول قصيره الاجل
وتقوموا بتسييس مشكله المناخ لتحقيق اهداف
سياسيه واقتصاديه بعيدا عن الحل الجوهري
للمشكله الاساسيه ولكن ما تفسير ذلك او ما
سبب ذلك يعني استاذ محمد هل نتحدث عن عدم
قدره او نتحدث عن اراده محدوده لهؤلاء
اساسه حضرتك حتى بينت العلاقه بين مناصبهم
وبين اقوالهم وبين تصريحاتهم همم هل هي
قدره عدم قدره على تفعيل اليه او
استراتيجيه معينه او ان الاراده محدوده
كذلك بمعنى انهم يفكرون على المدى القصير
كما تفضلت بالتلوح منذ قليل
صحيح هو لو اي سياسي في الدول المتقدم دول
العالم المتقدم اوجد حلول وفعلا نشتغل
عليها قد يعني وهذا غالبا تكون متعارضه مع
تحقيق اجنده السياسيه اللي اللي على
اساسها يحاول يحققها على المثل القصير
وبالتالي الافضل يلجا الى يعني تزيين او
تحسين صورته اقتصاديا وسياسيا على المدى
القصير على حساب حل المشكله الاساسيه
وطبعا الحل هو توجيه اللون لدول اخرى
بعيده تماما عن المشكله وحل المشكله
حضرتك تحدثت عن دول الخليج وقلت بانه همم
بدات تستشف همم
ان هذه الدول وكانها تعول على ان تتحرك
دول الخليج ان تتصرف دول الخليج همم وهي
همم يعني تحاول استفاده من كل ذلك فدول
الخليج في المقابل ما هو دورها ماذا في
امكان سعره حتى اولا تفسر لانه حضرتك تعرف
استاذ محمد موضوع المناخ وموضوع البيئه
وموضوع الطاقه هي ليست من المواضيع التي
يتابعها الجميع الا المعني بالموضوع او
الذي اصبح يهمه بشكل او باخر فما هو الدور
الذي يجب ان اا تلتزم به او على الاقل
تطور دول الخليج في هذا المجال
يعني دول الخليج مثل ما هو معروف هي جزء
من منظمه اوبك بلس يعني ودورها الاساسي هو
ضمان التوازن والاستقرار في الاسواق النفط
العالميه الان ما يحدث في اسواق النفط
الفحم او الغاز الطبيعي يعني مو كل الدول
معنيه يعني همم في هذه المشكله وبالتالي
حتى نوجد حلول يعني همم كل دوله احنا لا
ننسى انه مشكله المناخيه المشكله ان
الكوكب الكره الارضيه كامله مما يعني ان
جميع دول العالم مجتمعه لازم تتعاون وتوجد
حلول بجهد منسق في ما بينها دول الخليج
يعني الان قاعد تقوم بمبادرات يعني مثل ما
ذكرنا قبل شوي بالنسبه للمملكه او بالنسبه
الشرق الاوسط او بعض الدول
الشرق الاوسط ايضا تقوم بمبادرات متماشه
مع مبادرات المملكه وايضا بعض الدول
الاخرى لكن هذا لك في احنا نتكلم عن الدول
العالم ككل يعني لا بد من تطوير مثلا
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده مثل المملكه اقدمت
عليها المفروض ان الدول المتقدمه الكبرى
ايضا تقدم وبشكل يعني كبير في هذا المجال
ايضا في موضوع الهيدروجين الاخضر لكن الى
الان يعني الدول الصناعيه الكبرى مع الاسف
تفاعلها بطيء جدا اييي لم تنفذ اي شيء
ملموس وحتى
الدول
خلينا نسال في هذه النقطه ضيفنا بجهز معنا
من باريس دكتور
المناخ والكوارث الطبيعيه اهلا بك معنا
دكتور في الواقع كنا نتحدث عن موضوع
تنقضاعه التي
رصدها البعض في تصريحات اساس في الغرب
وظيفه كان يقول بانه هناك بطئ في التعامل
اساس في الغرب مع امكانيه ان تكون هناك
كثره التوجيهات حقيقيه وحتى تصريحاتهم
تخالف تماما افعالهم وفي فرنسا تبعنا حتى
بعض التصريحات في المانيا كذلك هناك حتى
توجه للفحم التقليدي بدلا من محاوله ايجاد
حلول همم ناجعه
في نفس الوقت تحافظ على موضوع الطاقه
والمناخ ما رايك
نعم منذ اشهر نشهد في دول العالم وخاصه في
الدول الغنيه والصناعيه
نوع من
الهفوه ومنوع من الارتباك ونوع من مازك
الدول موجوده فيه لاننا لم نكن نتوكل همم
خروج من جائحه الكورونا لم نكن نتوكل
الحرب في اوكرانيا لم نكن مستعدين الى
مشاكل جو سياسيه والى مشاكل ايضا اقتصاديه
والى الركود الاقتصادي كل ذلك تجمع خلال
السبع اشهر الماضيه ليجعل مسار مكافحه
التغير المناخ صعبا ومحقدا والدول الغنيه
لها مسؤوليه في هذا الامر بالطبع همم بغض
النظر عن هذه المشاكل ان الدول الغنيه لا
تفي بالالتزامات او الثالثه كفي جزئيا
بالالتزامات الذي تتخذها في مؤتمرات مع
تغير المناخ وفي غيرها من المنصات
لو سمحت حضرتك تتكلم عن ظروف هي التي دفعت
باساسها في الغرب لاتخاف مثل هكذا قرارات
ولكن الباص في المقابل يقول بانه طرف او
بعيدا عن هذه الظروف همم هناك تحركات
وهناك اجراءات يتخذها اساسا في الغرب لا
تساعد في بناء ستجيه حقيقيه لحلم اخضر همم
همم يعني على سبيل المثال فرض الدول
الاوروبيه غرائب تبلغ 200 بالمئه على
البترول وفي الوقت نفسهم يقدمون مساعدات
للفحم وهو همم من اسوا طرق همم او من اسوء
انواع الطاقه فكيف يفسر ذلك
نعم نحن في خيبه امل المجموعه الدوليه
المهتمه بامور المناخ هي في خيبه امل هذا
العام لان الاهداف الذي اتخذت والتفك
عليها في مؤتمر جلاسكو منذ عام يعني همم
يعني الابتعاد كليا بحلول عام 2030 التخلص
كليا من الاعتماد على الفحم الحجري هذا
الهدف هو الان صعب المنال نشهد ان الدول
الان عادت الى استعمال الفحم للاسف في هذا
خيبه امل ونكسه كبيره لمسار تغير المنا-
كذلك اهداف التمويل للدول الناميه لكي
ايضا تنتقل الى طاقات متجدده وخاصه الدعم
دول الناميه للتكيف كذلك هذا الهدف الذي
التزمت به الدول الغنيه منذ العام 2015
منذ اتفاقيه هذا الهدف هو صعب التحقيق
اليوم كل ذلك يتطلب منا وعي وادراك
وتضافر الجهود يجب ان نبتعد عن الجدل وان
نتخذ اجراءات على الارض يعني نعرف ان
المجموعه الدوليه والامم المتحده ليست
مثاليه في اتخاذ ربما قرارات هامه ولكن
الوضع يتطلب تضحيات من الجميع وخاصه من
الدول الناميه والغنيه التي هي طبعا عندها
مسؤوليه في هذا الامر واذا الامر قليل
يقول لك بانه ليست فقط
همم في المقابل هي التي تتحمل او ستحمل
هذه المسؤوليه استاذ محمد اترك لك تعليق
الاخيره على ما تفضل بها ضيفه هو يقول هذه
مسؤوليه المشتركه للكل ولكن لما نشاهد بان
دول تدعم استرشيات حقيقيه وتفعلها في حين
دول اخرى تتناقص بين تصريحاتها وافعالها
كيف يمكن ان يتكون هذا المشروع على
المستوى الدولي
هو طبعا يعني نرجع الى المسببات مثل ما
ذكرتنا قبل شويه اكثر من 75% من المتسببين
بمشكله ال- همم
الاحتباس الحراري على اكثر على مدى اكثر
من 200 عام هي مثل ما ذكرنا دول امريكا
الشماليه الولايات المتحده وكندا دول
اوروبا الصين اليابان روسيا الهند جنوب
افريقيا هذول يشكلون اكثر من 75% من مشكله
الاحتباس الحراري وبالتالي اذا افترضنا
المعادله على الورق المفترض ان الفاتوره
ايضا 75% تحملونهم لكن ومع هذا هم ايضا لم
يفعلوا اي شيء تجاه هذا الامر ومثل ما
ذكرته قبل شويه موضوع تقرير صندوق النقد
الدولي ان ان مشكله ارتفاع درجه الحراره
لن تكون بتاثيرات متساويه على دول العالم
مما يعني ان الدول الفقيره او الوسط خلينا
نقول اللي هي اللي هتتاثر اكثر من الدول
الصناعيه الكبرى ال- ال- المشكله مثل ما
تفضل اضيفك الكريم يعني مشكله الفحم على
سبيل المثال ارتفع انتاج من العام الماضي
الى الان تقريبا 1% مثل ما وهذا يتناقض مع
قرارات الدول يعني اللي تحاول ان تقلل من
انتاج واعتمادها على النفخ على الفحم
وهناك ثلاث دول يعني على سبيل المثال زاد
انتاجها من الفحم حوالي 8% في اخر سنه وهي
تحديدا الصين والهند والجنوب افريقيا وهذا
كارثه في الحقيقه ان دول يعني لها وزنها
اقتصاديه ولها مسؤوليه اجتماعيه على على
كوكب الكره الارضيه تزيد استخدامها
واستهلاكها للفحم بنسبه ثمانيه في المئه
خلال اخر سنه وهذا معناه يعني انهم ضربوا
بضربوا بعرض الحائط جميع الانظمه
والمفاهيم الاخلاقيه والبيئيه همم دون اي
اهتمام
سيبقى للمتابعه سنكتبه بهذا القدر على ان
نناقشه في حلقه اخرى اود شكرا لكم جزيلا
شكرا من رياض محمد العمران رئيس مركز
الخليجي للاستشارات الماليه شكرا لك ومن
باريس دكتور بدوره خبره تغير المناخ
والكوارث الطبيعيه شكرا لكم